let's all just rally together from Megan
Merkel to Queen Elizabeth the Royals are
rallying together to take precautionary
measures amid coronavirus concerns on
Tuesday Buckingham Palace announced that
the 93 year old Queen will move to
Windsor Castle for the Easter week
period on March 19th
that's one week earlier than planned and
she'll likely stay there past the
holiday what's more the three garden
party's Elizabeth was scheduled to host
in May all canceled so is the annual
Maundy service at st. George's Chapel on
April 9th plans for trooping the colour
and the Emperor and Empress of Japan
state visit are still TBD and / the
palace they'll be made in due course in
consultation with the government
meanwhile it was previously announced
that Prince Charles and Camilla are
scratching their spring royal tour of
Bosnia Cyprus and Jordan due to kovat 19
whenever and wherever adversity strikes
the people who the United Kingdom have a
unique ability to pull together
Prince William had this message for
Instagram followers on Wednesday now
more than ever I'm grateful for the
national emergencies trust exists it
will ensure the support reaches those
across the UK who need it most as
quickly and efficiently as possible as
for how the pandemic is personally
affecting the 37 year old Prince he and
wife Kate Middleton's two eldest kids
Prince George and Princess Charlotte are
about to start remote learning their
last day of the term at Thomas's
Battersea might be March 26 but ET has
learned that they will move to remote
learning this Friday four year old
Princess Charlotte joined her big
brother at the London School last
September meanwhile Megan Markel and
Prince Harry are back in Canada after
completing their final events as senior
Royals and on Wednesday they took to
Instagram with a message of solidarity
writing in part quote these are
uncertain times and now more than ever
we need each other they went on to
acknowledge those working tirelessly to
respond to this crisis quote this moment
is as true a testament there is to the
human spirit
they addressed how COBIT 19 is uniting
each of us globally stay tuned for more
from Megan and Harry as they promised to
keep sharing information and resources a
fantastic team we know real in the
meantime a source tells ET that the
sussex a--'s are taking appropriate
measures and they're following
government advice regarding the
coronavirus adding that they will act
accordingly if and when they are
specifically made aware of being in
contact with someone who's tested
positive
[Music]